that we're worried about ecosystems that
we really found human that's we were
worried about invasive species on when
new species get introduced to new
ecosystems it's like we were just
talking about this yesterday everglades
like people are doing whatever the fuck
they can to get the pythons and the
Africans they these assholes have
released pythons and there's a real
fuckin redneck Jurassic Park going on in
the middle of Florida yeah you know we
care I lived in Miami man and at the
time I lived in Miami talk about you did
radio out there right yeah I 100 miles
after fear factor after fear factor it
landed me that big gig radio was radio
back there oh yeah it was it was like
huge man but I remember they had these
lakes and if you go back like ten years
ago and look up Florida people were just
jogging around lakes getting snatched by
alligators yeah like just alligators did
not give a damn that it was just
snatching people yeah and I was like why
are people jogging like like stopped
jogging well we definitely don't jog
near the water no and that's the thing I
believe like eight people within six
months got snatched just jogging my real
Oh a hundred percent probably about
eight to ten years ago just jogging I
didn't know that that there was that
many deaths ever from Allan oh yeah they
were getting snatched one of my favorite
ones was a guy who was running from the
cops near Miami and he was in a stolen
car parked his car on a bridge jumped
off the bridge and landed on an
alligator I'll get a jacked him in front
of the cops and they were just sitting
there going well up there you go guilty
jumps off the bridge splash that would
be this look oh my god - oh that guy
didn't even notice until last minute no
that's what I'm saying like that happens
in Florida at that time that is so crazy
that is such a big thing that eats deer
and shit look at it opens its mouth on
them but meanwhile it tries to get away
from people well what's interesting to
do didn't even speed up yeah like I
really tired
to fuck these things man fuck these
things but the craziest thing is when we
were showing it yesterday that pythons
eat them alligators whole but not to one
Python ate this fucking big-ass
alligator and it blew its body apart
apparently another alligator came along
while it had it in its body and tried to
eat the Python and so then it was like
this disaster of a Python with an
alligator inside of it with no head oh
yeah but the whole thing was that this
Python and ate the alligator and then
once they eat it they can't move because
they got a fucking 900 pound alligator
but you love that shit I can't take out
I I know you do you do problem with them
I just I love animals eating other
animals I think it's important to
recognize that we're we're we're very
insulated from what the fuck is going on
by cities yes and that in houses and
cities and even towns even if you have a
town it's rare that a fucking wild
predator makes its way into your town
mm-hm
but man that's the whole rest of the
world that's the whole world including
the ocean everywhere is all just
predators and prey predators and prey
predators and prey we've figured out a
way to insulate but in insulation the
problem is when we rice elated from it
we neglect it as an aspect of nature we
put it in some weird box oh my god this
is weird no that's not weird that's
normal yeah that's normal life normal
life is big things eating a little earth
and you don't respect it god it really
don't respect it when you don't see it
like yeah my parents want to go to
Africa on a safari I'm like man you can
have that yeah I would go if I got one
of them like Jurassic Park Mobile's that
they have with it's all in it you see
these people are just in regular jeeps
where they gave their jeeps where Lions
just walk about like how dumb are you
and most the time nothing happens no
most most of it but it could be one or
two times where if you're in it you know
a years ago a woman who worked on Game
of Thrones she was there on vacation and
she got pulled out of her fucking car
right she rolled down the window to take
a picture and the cat came and snatched
her out of the car but don't you think
people kind of like that deserve it like
people that roll down Windows and not
safer like that's like people jumping in
the pit at the zoo the other day well
they take a selfie the roll down
windows thing I think is really just
it's what we're talking about that
you're not around it in there so you
don't understand what it is but do you
have to be around it to know hey these
are wild animals and think they can get
away with shit if they've never had
anything happen to them like I've never
been punched oh this this is a cheetah
cheetahs are actually not there they're
actually very curious and they're not
dangerous to people so this dude has no
idea this thing is in his back seat
no he's filming it oh he's filming it so
he's not moving don't move I think so
man I think the move is don't move you
don't want to scare him you definitely
don't want to go here fucking rip your
face off
they don't have claws they don't have
claws like a cat does they're more like
a dog yeah you know they're a weird
animal they're like a weird cat dog
thing you know they're super super fast
like I've never seen one run in real
life but apparently people who I know
that I've seen and say you can't believe
how fast it is you know one thing that
blew me away I was reading about it that
hippopotamuses kill more people year
than all the animals combined all of
them all of them yeah all of them and
it's just like people just like don't
respect hippopotamuses in they're fast
and they're strong and they'll rip you
apart yeah they're like a giant pig yeah
they're in the pig family look about
cousin to a pig or some shit yeah and
they're vegetarians yeah like they're
just killing people estimated 500 people
per year and they kill 500 a year
they're aggressive and they're very
sharp teeth and not only that man people
think there's 750 kilograms what what is
that dude 7 pounds that's more than
5,000 pounds yet 2.2 times that so oh my
god that's that's well people don't
respect because they think they're slow
too so when they see them I think they
run like 24 25 miles per hour we're like
a hundred a person that runs a 100-yard
dash in the Olympics
I think average around like 29 to 30
miles per hour this hippos 19 mile okay
so that's still fast yeah you're barely
getting away well that's me I probably
can't run 19 miles now I know I couldn't
I'll probably get eaten fuck can you
imagine you're like 20 yards away from
this thing like ah it's not
and then it just runs up on you well
they say if you ever get chased by an
alligator - the thing is - Jew come go
left and go right that pictures
terrifying scares the shit out of me
that scares the shit out of me I mean
look at that guy's he's he's he's
launching himself in the air trying to
not look at that yeah they chase after
boats in the water they swim fast yeah
they try 500 people a year dude hippos
husband sees hippo bite out wife's heart
what oh my god imagine wife falls into
the water and you see the hippo rip open
a ribcage
oh I would be a hippo Punisher I would
go back to Africa every year and kill
that every one every one of them I'd be
responsible for hippo extinction they'd
be like you can't do that a bike but I'm
gonna - stop me don't I'm killing all
the hippos why not
I'm killing all the snakes for if
everybody anyone knew got killed what
the first day that something gets killed
by a fucking Python in Florida when a
human gets jacked we should send in the
Marines Jesus go through the fucking
swamp and kill them all just like
they're the enemy you just get a giant
line of human beings go through and kill
those fucking serpents they're in the
Bible okay yeah they're in the Bible
snakes elite your baby they will I mean
are they cocky with monsters living in
your fucking neighborhood is there any
purpose of them though yeah they killed
rats but the problem is in that area
it's not established for them so there
was this rich ecosystem of mammals and
reptiles you're talking about Everglades
right now yeah okay it used to be there
were some snakes like hot and mouse and
stuff like that and there was alligators
but then there was like marsh hares and
raccoons and skunks gone they're all
gone they're gone there's nothing left
there's just anacondas look event
pythons and Nile crocodiles now if this
is another one eating a fucking well let
me ask you something and be honest with
me if that guy got eaten like a guy that
actually tracks
reptiles do you feel sorry for like if
you put yourself in harm's way yeah
because I want that guy to be out there
look into an eye of a snake and you go
oh this thing doesn't give a fuck about
anybody it's like it does it I was
watching this video of a crab and it's a
crab a mother crab just sitting there
eating its babies it had like thousands
of babies all around it that had just
hatched like a couple of weeks ago and
it's just sitting there eating its
babies and I'm like yeah yeah fuck you
yeah you're going in the boiling water
and I'm gonna crack you open I'm here if
I heard him scream when they go in a
bullring oh yeah I don't think they're
really screaming I think it's probably
air escaping their body look at this
cunt they're kids
this is crazy I was I was at a friend's
house and they caught crabs and they
would throw him it and I think they
screamed man I think it's like vocal
cords video Jamie for people to just
listen it says monster red crab eats
babies the dark side of nature yeah
she's an ass I'm telling you Joe they
make a noise when you put him in a hot
boiling pot of water
what is that bottom of her she's got a
charcoal briquette stuck under her
doesn't that look like one of those
where the baby's gonna come right back
out is so gross she's such an asshole
she just sitting there eating her kids
like that anybody would give a fuck
about crabs oh well I'm not like I want
him to go extinct but that's one animal
that we in our house kill ourselves and
no one has a problem with it it's like
if they brought him a rabbit and you
gotta throw it in the water like fatal
attractions it's like that was the only
way to keep nobody would eat wrap no no
no no and we throw them in like a lot
most the time most people even bother to
take it off for lobsters yeah and
lobsters we do not give a shit get in
there get in hey fucking bug